feel like brendan's shop exploded and
then he had a moment to calm down yeah
but he already set this fire and brian
it in brian and then he went over to
talk to rogan about it but as he started
getting you know his senses back he's
thinking to himself what the [ __ ] have i
done what have i done and i like how joe
rogan's just like everyone's dad
yeah i feel like they run too and
they're like yo let's talk about this
this is why i'm saying look by the way i
think brian callen is so [ __ ] funny
right but his be in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius in five four three
two one hello everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast oh wow we are the number one
podcast
in all of uh spotify yeah you know this
yeah hey dude it's new yeah
yeah
above them
never heard of them yeah never heard who
who's tiger belly yeah we're above uh
what's it called the one with andrew
schultz yeah flagrant the one playgroud
the first and the second one more like
not so flagrant am i right in your face
yeah yeah yeah yeah damn boys it's quite
tame if you ask me
what uh what's the fighter in the kid
suck my nuts yeah yeah
never heard of them either yeah speaking
of that huh
we're going right into it dude so i just
came back from korea okay korea and you
know every now and then i'm checking out
that race
and then
everybody's like you got to talk about
the brenda's shop and uh tiger belly
thing brendan shaw and tiger belly thing
it was a requested time there's a
request this is the most request i'm
talking about in my instagram dms the
email everything so and you know people
generally when they kind of like
something you'll see like three or four
i'm talking about everybody wanted me to
talk about the situation because and
you've been on both podcasts yeah
because they think i have some insider
information and i don't number one just
to put it out i don't know brendan shop
like i was on his podcast and that's it
and he was nice to me then and that's
how we left it at and that came on my
podcast and i said his stand-up special
was terrible
you said that before
you said that before before and after
before and after yeah well i said it
during his podcast too yeah yeah yeah
you asked him about it well yeah i
wanted to say what's up with the shitty
stand up
it's a great segue that's pretty good
well he's like hi
because i said it on my podcast
my name's david you suck
can i come on twitter
yes no but the reason why i wanted the
because i'm just generally curious
because he knows that nobody liked his
first special it's not something that's
not known yeah and if he's saying that
if he if me asking that he was surprised
and he's living in a hole but um so when
i i have to keep the same energy i can't
come on to his podcast and say hey i
loved your special and that's why people
like you david that's why people [ __ ]
you oh why thank you yeah that's why
you're the number one podcast
in all of youtube joe who joe joe
yeah you know
yeah anyways guys
yeah yeah yeah anyways yeah anyways guys
that's a tough one yeah more like joe
[ __ ]
yeah
billionaire
yeah [ __ ] rich bastard it was good
that was good yeah but that was good the
whole
tiger belly thing that happened
oh i had so i was on a plane and i
downloaded the uh the podcast because
your boy got youtube premium damn all
right for you
i spend that [ __ ] eight dollars a
month yo dave hey david's doing okay in
life you know right you could afford
youtube premium that's real [ __ ] yes
right
i don't really know the six-year-old
vinnie piece girl did these uh shoes for
us so you know you boy got it pretty
good but i downloaded the whole thread
and i had to listen to the whole podcast
and it was a very interesting thing
because number one just right off the
jump like i said i don't really know
brendan shaw and bobby and i you know we
met each other six or seven times but
we're not like
you know he's not calling me for advice
we're not like hanging out 24 7. yeah
dude yeah but i he's somebody that i
genuinely care about he's been always
super nice to me and i think i have a
general feel about him just because i
say like you know let's say hours spent
we probably spent like whatever 10 hours
together total which is not much
but
having seen this whole debacle right it
was just a really awkward thing to watch
it was so [ __ ] awkward and at the
same time hilarious because the premise
of this whole thing if you guys don't
know is that it all stemmed from this
early on um trash tuesday podcast right
trash tuesday is kalila uh annie
letterman and esther pavitsky's podcast
right annie letterman and esther povisky
are stan female standard comics and then
kalila are friends and they kind of made
their own thing
so they told the story on the podcast
where they were talking about a not
funny comic that tried to [ __ ] him right
not esther pavitsky for some reason she
was left out
she was just in the corner like what
about me
but
annie letterman and uh kalila alluded to
this comic didn't say his name
that uh tried to [ __ ] him and obviously
these are like hints that everybody's
kind of like oh they're talking about
brendan's shop so annie letterman
basically said that hey there's this
non-funny comic who tried to get me to
walk into his car like what the [ __ ] am
i supposed to blow you in your truck
um and kalila talked about this time
where that same comic hit on
her i forgot what this specific app was
like d'amder yeah he dm they're
basically uh wanting to [ __ ] right
that person apparently turns out to be
brendan shop and this is during the time
that he is married i think or not i
don't know it could be i don't know if
he was married or not but it was like i
think on the podcast they said it was
like six or seven years ago seven years
ago so if you were still with this lady
then then it was during the time that he
was with his other lady sure which
already is yeah [ __ ] foul as [ __ ]
that honestly that's the first and last
strike for me man yeah it's like you
your strike was his first special
bro but i'm kidding
don't fight me wow bro but it's like you
know that's your homies girl mm-hmm and
you slide in her dms like what are you
doing we got beef yeah what are you
doing that's forever beef you know what
i mean yeah that's crazy i don't know
that's just me but so he was just
hitting her up i don't know where it was
like yo let's like kind of [ __ ] type
[ __ ] don't know the specifics but
essentially that's essentially that's
what it was okay so and this is somebody
that he says here's here's the thing
that i really really dislike probably
about brendan not from a personal
experience but what this kind of shows
about
uh his character as a human being is
that i dislike people who say the word
that's my brother that's my friend and
they're not stop saying that [ __ ] stop
saying to people he says it consistently
because i watched the fighter in the kid
that's my brother man he's like a
brother to me brendan shut the [ __ ] up
he is not your friend he is a work
acquaintance that you guys have good
jokes with they say good things about
you that doesn't mean that in your
[ __ ] circle what are you [ __ ] 13
years old are you [ __ ] dumb you don't
know what friends are yet do you have no
[ __ ] real friends and if that's the
case that's your bad yeah you've
surrounded around you surrounded
yourself around people who like to throw
these words out that's my brother that's
my friend that's my boy so many people
in this [ __ ] city say that [ __ ] so
often it's just glued to their [ __ ]
lying lips brendan bobby lee is not your
friend he was never your friend you guys
were cool with each other those are two
[ __ ] big differences yeah and those
guys say those words so often and so and
the idea behind that the reason why that
kind of annoys me is that for you to go
on the podcast right which is cool
that's fine you're trying to bury the
hatchet or you're trying to you know
save skin right now
because he's honestly on the back foot
like lyla was saying
is that
you're saying that this is my brother
how would this is how you treat your
family that's the crazy part
right what is this what is this
definition of friendship and brotherhood
that you keep [ __ ] saying stop saying
that [ __ ] that's the only thing that
annoyed me you can't do that type of
[ __ ] bro yeah that's unforgivable like
you're you're trying to [ __ ] this guy
who says he's somebody you look up to
that you admire and appreciate you
trying to [ __ ] his [ __ ] girlfriend
get the [ __ ] out of here you're lying
and it's and it's weird because like
i'm sure you feel some type of way about
like who bobby is you know what i mean
it's like you think you can get away
with that yeah you don't think like you
think kawhila told him yeah you don't
think that's gonna come out
and for sure bobby knew already yeah and
at the same time here's the thing that
[ __ ] me up they talked about on soccer
before too okay oh really well six seven
years right
he comes on the podcast and actually
nothing happened yeah and then they
brush they brush right by it yeah and
it's like no no that's that's where it
really starts i think yeah personally
you tried to [ __ ] his girlfriend that's
that's the real elephant in the room
yeah yeah or you you you took the
attempt which is i think yeah
not okay it's not it's not it's
definitely not a cool thing to do yeah
like yo i'm gonna try to [ __ ] you your
wife yeah yeah like it's crazy not chill
it's just a little weird that he would
you know
i think people just kind of brush that
under the rug like yeah that's not a
brush under the rug type of [ __ ] right
that's a [ __ ] that's you getting
murdered type of [ __ ] like you don't
have to do that
it's like obviously nobody's going to do
[ __ ] to brenda's shop you're a former
top 10 heavyweight in the ufc and you're
on gear who's very very long i'm talking
about like with birthdays too like
comedians aren't like the toughest bunch
in the world
yeah but i mean like [ __ ] like to bobby
lee like come on now yeah i mean the guy
[ __ ] literally just got out of rehab
yeah and he and his body is all
misshapen like what the [ __ ] what are
you guys sorry bobby but he looks great
now yeah hey he lost some weight
but like what what are you gonna do like
what is bobby gonna do yeah is that why
you felt that you could just go ahead
and talk to his girl cause there was no
consequence
yeah that's important you gotta ask that
question yeah right you gotta ask that
question and in the podcast you kind of
like go through some of the comments
which a lot of these people who are
writing these comments are
you know hugely the fire in the kid fans
right yeah they're like oh and they're
you know [ __ ] on kalila yeah giving
her hate bro
here's the thing why for me i'm trying
to look at this and like i don't really
know kaleila like that we don't really
talk like that either but we're very
cordial with each other right
the thing that the weird part is like do
you see how kalila's like neurotic
behavior did you see how she had all
this evidence lined up and she had to
get her evidence out
that's the purpose of the podcast so of
course she was going to do that how is
that a point against her the reason why
they brought them on is to get the
timeline out and so they could see what
it really is about so for people to
write in the comments like yo that's her
being a a manipulative crazy person no
that's for being prepared where's she
[ __ ] amber heard here she's not going
to just walk in and start saying random
[ __ ] and fake cry it just makes sense
yeah shout out to amber hurd you have
thoroughly entertained me throughout my
13-hour flight we should we'll talk
about that yeah
but
the the weird whole the whole thing
about this too is this a lot of he said
she said stuff this is what i don't like
yeah
how do you go off and just start making
threats to somebody based on stuff that
you didn't look into you openly admit it
you didn't look into it he goes my team
said who's your [ __ ] team guy yeah
scooby doo [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is your
team yeah and he's just like basing off
this whole thing and he's patrick riley
patrick riley it's me
dude they're coming right now dude
they're talking [ __ ] about you right now
david here
the address how'd you find where i live
don't worry about it patrick did
but he's still rightly
i don't know if it's because his cte
[ __ ] flared up and in the moment this
is what i truly believe happened he
heard this [ __ ] from from
brian callan or somebody right
he starts getting [ __ ] mad and starts
going on a rampage and after all the
dust settles he goes what have i done
i [ __ ] up and now he's trying to you
know pick up the pieces after he just
threw a [ __ ] grenade and exploded
everything and now he's trying to be
like okay i i shouldn't have done this
but guess what you already got brian
callum pissed so brian callen is going
to do what [ __ ] dumb ass brian callan
does which is pretend to be this [ __ ]
tough guy
you know
that that's the part that makes the
whole reddit like the ip address thing
to like that bobby lee was a reddit
masterminder what are you insinuating
here bro no i'm saying like that whole
idea makes no [ __ ] sense at all like
i'm like
i it doesn't even i don't even
understand how somebody logically could
be like you're being really dismissive
about it bro like
give it something give us some time to
like sit a little bit victim blame her
yeah bro geez no actually it makes no
sense like what the [ __ ] do i the funny
thing is too on the podcast bobby was
like i don't even know how to use the
internet yeah and everybody says that
about him literally everybody like
crystal leah apparently texted bobby it
was like bro you don't know how to do
[ __ ] yeah he was like
he called him laughing like what the
[ __ ] everybody's like all of his friends
are messaging him just laughing at that
one part yeah because they know how
ridiculous it is because if you know
bobby like bro like bro what's it says
uh brendan shaw says that's his brother
then how do you not know this fool is
technologically inept for him to i don't
know how to use reddit reddit is so
complicated well i don't even understand
like because brian kellen and bobby lee
have known each other they both did mad
tv they've been like they've known each
other for a while
it's just like the the escalation like
if i was like
something my team told me nick is
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] on reddit about you
i am and you're [ __ ] bitch-ass and
like all this [ __ ] saying
i'm like i forgot bro spread the word
he's adorable dog
all this [ __ ]
um
first of all i'd be like why would nick
do that a and then but b i would like
call you and be like yo what like if i
really felt some kind of way i'd be like
hey i've heard this like what's going on
like to just be like i'ma [ __ ] ruin
your life because you like the the jump
is the part i don't understand
but that's what i'm saying why ruin your
career why were they so i mean i can
understand brendan being like on a
trigger because he he has been getting
hate for years about how he sucks as a
stand-up and like all that stuff yeah
those are just facts
like if your team sees this and you hear
through the grapevine about the things
that i've said about you it's true
patrick riley patrick wright
but like
like i i don't even i don't get where
brian calen like what what i just don't
understand did you hear his apology on
the fire of the kids the leap i saw a
piece of it but i just don't understand
the leap to that extreme well this is
the weird part right this is what i'm
saying i feel like brendan's shop
exploded and then he had a moment to
calm down yeah but he already set this
fire and brian and brian and then he
went over to talk to rogan about it but
as he started getting you know his
senses back he's thinking to himself
what the [ __ ] have i done what have i
done and i like how joe rogan's just
like everyone's dad
yeah i feel like they run too and
they're like yo let's talk about this
this is why i'm saying look by the way i
think brian callan is so [ __ ] funny
right but his behavior is so nuts no he
said he's a protector that's what he
said on the protector that's what that's
why he said he got upset and that's why
he blew up by bobby okay well let me
tell you that's what he said on his
podcast if i was out in the middle of a
street right and an asian attack
happened to me right and then brian
count was i got you i would look at him
and say i'm good
i got this myself yeah you stay over
there as i hear your knees and elbows
crack as you're walking up sound like
you [ __ ] just like [ __ ] bubble
wrap back the [ __ ] up i'm okay nobody
needs you to protect anybody yeah yeah
[ __ ] relax guy
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah he's
just walking him i got you i'm good and
i'm getting stabbed repeatedly it's okay
i'll take this one i'll take the l thank
you good god
i don't know if he did he get bullied
when he was a kid like what is going on
maybe or maybe he was the bully
maybe maybe i don't i don't know i like
i said i don't that's i i just it just
doesn't make sense i'm like how the [ __ ]
well the weird thing is too it's like
the
so there was this clip of joe rogan
referring to somebody right talking
about a situation which clearly sounds
like the tiger belly situation right
and
the the the [ __ ] fact that
i'm not saying is a fact because this is
all hearsay right but it's fun here
saying it's fun hearsay
if in fact that this is true just from
that clip that i saw alone and i went
back to the whole podcast uh it could
possibly be that it is a brendan shot
that he's referring to
but he's like okay this guy comes up he
starts talking to me about the situation
and then i'm telling him are you willing
to risk it all for the circumstantial
evidence that you're not even sure about
yeah does this make sense and i think
that is the moment where brendan was
like oh [ __ ]
what have i done
genius farts this podcast is sponsored
by better help my friends if you have
heard me talk about betterhelp a million
times and you're like oh my god david
not again you know why because i love
better help and i use it consistently i
need someone to talk to and it can't
always just be my personal friends who
have their biases i just need someone to
listen to me so i can feel better and
mental health is just important as my
physical health so i'm going to make
sure that my [ __ ] stays
sharp life can be super overwhelming my
friends and many people are burned out
without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation feeling
helpless or trapped whole bunch of no
no's in my life that i don't want and
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing the stress in your
life and that's where better help comes
in it's customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to and it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy yes
and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours genius brain
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com genius that's
betterhelp.com
genius
and he said there's a whole
investigation from the feds right which
he said that he misused the word feds
which wasn't him misusing that word in
my personal opinion it was him trying to
make the situation a lot bigger to scare
people to make them feel bad for him
yeah be [ __ ] honest just be [ __ ]
nobody misuses the word feds for
somebody just looking into something in
at reddit right which by the way already
doesn't make sense to me because that's
not how red that's their jurisdiction
though yeah that's the federal
government's yeah they just go into
reddit
because everything on reddit is real
yeah there's no [ __ ] way sure so the
weird sketchy part is that on the
podcast he states like hey after this
podcast is done i'll show you everything
all 300 pages whatever because he said
it was 300 pages of evidence
they did a second podcast because they
were supposed to talk about it he didn't
show them [ __ ] he lied he went to their
phone he showed a zoomed up thing of
like some source code and then the
because he was saying in the whole
podcast that tiger belly
that they linked this account that was
doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ] spreading
hate to the tiger belly gmail account
and they had the source code and zoomed
in
with the email and then
a name under it robert lee but it was
all source code and it was like zoomed
in and that was like the only thing they
showed but there was no context so
that's why they're like well
what is this
i don't know what this is i don't know
what i'm looking at if you're just
looking at a bunch of source code with
you know like
does that necessarily mean
that's who's been behind it the whole
time yeah what does that mean and then
their point is like look if that's our
[ __ ] email well now we didn't know if
we got our [ __ ] hacked
so if our shit's [ __ ] hacked our
email said we're [ __ ] that's connected
to all of our accounts wow but then
later on like i guess like brendan
doesn't respond and he comes out with
the thing saying hey look my team and i
are going to handle it and we don't feel
comfortable sharing this information
with you but you literally said that you
were going to do it after the podcast
yeah so there's just too much weird
backing a lot of he said she said [ __ ]
yeah for him to go on this whole like
tiraden mission to take bobby lee down
and confront him and threaten him over
something he didn't even look into
himself is [ __ ] stupid
like it's dumb especially if he's your
brother and friend yeah if i heard like
i don't know let's say oh you know joe
and bart were talking [ __ ] about you
right i'll be like probably
you know i probably into something dumb
yeah and they probably said to my face
yeah right and i would just leave it at
that because that's the relationship
that we had
like it would never even get to the
point where i have to take joe and
barton's side is this what you said yeah
because if i really am their brethren or
brother or whatever i would be like okay
it was probably because i did this dumb
thing and they were saying how stupid it
was which is true and that just happened
before maybe not with them but other
people where i've done something dumb
and they're like oh they somebody told
me that you did this i was like yep
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so i just found it really
childish how this whole thing happened
off of somebody getting mad over
something he heard through somebody else
it makes no [ __ ] something that he
like
did you know like it started from this
like maybe not with the annie letterman
[ __ ] or whatever at least with the
kalila story it's like so he said on the
podcast like yeah i talked to bobby
about it you know we squashed it but at
the same time it's like
about what him like hitting on college
and you can't be mad that they're
talking about it like does it happen you
did it you know like i don't know like
it's just kind of wild to me yeah yeah i
mean i don't know damn they oh the whole
thing makes no [ __ ] sense to me i was
just like the escalation yeah the
escalation doesn't makes zero sense like
brian callan to threatening bobby with
joe rogan is the biggest pussiest thing
i've ever heard in my life i'm gonna
tell my daddy on you yeah right it's
like what are you doing dude
and also too bobby knows joe rogan and
also joe rogan seems like the kind of
guy that'd be like i'm staying the [ __ ]
out of this weirdo [ __ ] that's why
i'm in austin bro i'm pretty sure joe
rogan was like listen that's your thing
don't ask me for advice yeah what am i
going to do just lay down the hatchet
and [ __ ] start chopping people's
heads yeah like what what do i do yeah
what it's like i'm a billionaire you
guys you can't go on the podcast anymore
sorry
[Laughter]
what was going to happen yeah the idea
that brian callan threatened bobby with
joe rogan is the sorriest saddest thing
i've ever heard in my life what's weird
too is that like they there's uh like a
pattern like with bobby lee and then
ariel helwani it's like there's all
these like weird little conflicts that
they keep getting into it's like because
of his mouth eventually it's like okay
who's the problem you know aaron hewani
is there everybody [ __ ] knows dude he
went hard bro he went harder well he
went to hawaii he's still throwing shots
too destroyed brendan shop he went back
so hard dude like i've never liked ariel
helwani so much in my life not because
he was doing to brenda's shop because
how he dealt with that situation yeah
like him just going like oh okay i'm
gonna call brenda's shop right now i
want the apology live and yeah honestly
it kind of reminded me of david
he just comes up he goes
pick up your phone
just like that so he was so g the whole
time i was like i didn't know this dude
had it in him to be this he did like a
30 minute monologue just going in they
would just put hit him up in the
background
yeah [ __ ] that pool too
like hell yeah dude what's going on [ __ ]
joe
and the ironic thing was that on tiger
belly he was talking about for brendan
he goes i'm okay you know i'm a comic
i'm an entertainer you could make fun of
me talk about me being a stat a bad
stand-up or whatever right but when you
go you know after me personally and my
family and this stuff is toxic how funny
you did the same thing to ariel helwani
how funny brendan that you literally
said on your podcast i heard through
hearsay which apparently you're really
good at just regurgitating stuff stuff
through hearsay that ariel helwani is a
bad uh [ __ ] co-host and a terrible
person to work with the network's hate
that's crazy and you're going after his
[ __ ] money and now his family you did
the same thing what are you talking
about
yeah what is this nonsense
and listen
on this podcast too we say some [ __ ] but
guess what in my stories i change all
the [ __ ] names and half the details
are flipped out you know what cause i
come from a very small town like you
tell these stories you can't tell them
straight up because everybody knows who
that is you should all do the same any
story that you've heard unless people
that you guys know the names are all
flipped and if i forget i bleep it out
in the podcast yeah so it's like there's
none of that [ __ ] with them and they
think that they could just do whatever
the [ __ ] they want which i understand
maybe a story from 50 60 years ago 30
years ago 20 years ago it might be okay
because who the [ __ ] cares about this
[ __ ] right but at the end of the day
you're talking about somebody who's a
constituent in your space which kind of
goes back to with kalila too i want to
think that kaleida got [ __ ] for it was
because she kind of threw it off as
giggly girl talk which is a little
unfair yeah you know yeah when you said
that [ __ ]
you kind of know what's gonna happen on
the internet the internet is gonna take
it take it and then [ __ ] ride it out
right so kalyla did [ __ ] up on that part
that there were shots yeah she was
throwing some harsh shots right and yeah
it is giggly girl talk but once again
this is the internet and kalila also
knows how hurtful the internet can be
which they admitted to that they don't
really read comments because of that so
she should also know that when you say
that type of stuff you understand the
consequences that are gonna come out of
it right so she has to own up to that so
when she says giggly girl talk i
understand but at the same time you're
in the space you you should kind of know
or foresee what's gonna happen yeah but
then at the same time
maybe you shouldn't have tried to [ __ ]
her that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that's your homies
like girl
yeah i don't know that just blows my
[ __ ] that is crazy that really blows
my mind dude bobby is so hilarious at
the end of the podcast it's so good
brendan goes
because probably i just wanna let you
know i love you and then bobby goes i
wish i could say the same he does
he said that yeah
at the end i started dying laughing i
think you're right about like the people
that say like this is my brother like
this is because you're right because
it's so we like i've had that too where
people i've had guys be like oh i love
you dude and i just kind of was like
i i didn't feel it back so i didn't say
i look you know i don't know like i'll
tell you guys how to play it off hey man
i love you dude i just i he was looking
at me and i was like
cool like i just said cool
like i don't love you back in for a kiss
and show me you love him
it was the guy from the gym
[ __ ] sweetheart
uh but yeah no you're right like that is
a that is a red flag when someone's
constantly like this person remember and
you barely know him it's like you know
what about what are you doing one of the
biggest advice i always give to these
kids too and you know what i got to stop
saying talk to the kids just talk to the
kids talk to the kids talk to the kids
let them know children
yeah davidson woman right drugs are fun
do all of this they are pretty good
right
pretty good weed is not addictive
cocaine even better
but
stop [ __ ] on the first date a lot of
like girls like who are subscribers they
always bring up the same email and i
never talk about the [ __ ] about this
advice column because it's always the
same [ __ ] i thought i knew this person i
always asked them the same thing how
long did you know them plus nobody they
knew them for they met him six months
ago yeah you don't know them you don't
know them you met each other at cabo you
had a couple of drinks
you know somebody ran a train on you
whatever whatever whatever [ __ ] hot
trouble [ __ ] hot
hot i'm hard i've never masturbated to
an email so much in my life
so
i'm coming i'm okay
so you [ __ ] met this person you had a
great time you guys were drunk that's
that one experience yeah you don't know
them yeah but then they go this is my
girlfriend do i [ __ ] love her she's
the best
she's not you don't know her you had a
good time here yeah you don't know who
the [ __ ] this person is so when they do
weird [ __ ] to you that's because you
didn't know that you didn't know them
this is who they are yeah
they didn't change
you didn't change either the only
difference is that you trusted them they
didn't trust you and so you got a little
hurt from it stop [ __ ] on the first
date so even for brenda's shop like my
question to him would be who are your
friends who is in your [ __ ] circle
because clearly at this point
the people in your circle aren't doing a
very [ __ ] good job and i'm not
talking about his staff i'm talking
about his friends i don't know i don't
like i met chen i met him they're all
[ __ ] dope right
who is in your personal circle because
clearly they would have never allowed
you to put out that second special like
that that [ __ ] was bad and that's how
we're ending the podcast
the podcast is over number one podcast
spotify no i'm kidding i'm kidding like
i'm not that nice i'm joking but i did
not like it
and that's
what did you like about watching someone
watching i
the one clip about his kid calling him
but though and he didn't know what that
meant
i thought that was funny you did did you
laugh how hard you like did you go ha ha
ha ha i was like dude i only saw a
couple clips from his first special but
the funniest part is one click on the
youtube of a second special i was like
oh this is funnier than the first one
this is better than that so here's the
smirk yeah i was like and me and tiff
are watching it she was like oh yeah
that's pretty funny
oh we did like that
we went we went
once you hit that octave it's alive
tiffany's like oh yeah i like doctor
strange that's pretty good that's what
she said oh no shane was great
were you talking about david yeah but uh
i'll say this better than his first
special for sure yeah i mean yeah
rock bottom it's pretty hard not to go
up from there so it's like his first
special was really really really bad
i think he was only doing comedy for a
year a year or maybe two years maybe two
yeah which is insane that's tough it's
great i think the only other person that
did that was
i think eddie murphy shot raw and that's
like his third or fourth year third year
of doing stand-up oh right that could be
wrong eight correct me but that's eddie
though that's unbelievable yeah that's
true because those that's special is
hilarious yeah i think eddie murphy was
only doing comedy for maybe a couple
years when he shot that special so
there's only so good but that's [ __ ]
eddie murphy yeah that's right he's like
one of a kind that's michael jordan type
of [ __ ] that's lebron james [ __ ] yeah
you know so let's let's not compare it
you know because okay i i think his
second special was better than his first
but his he keeps going through these
same tropes right and his constant joke
throughout the whole thing was him
talking about his not being mexican-ness
for 30 minutes yeah it was the bit was
too long it was just the same type of
trope and jokes throughout the whole
[ __ ] thing and the thing that he
doesn't do very well which i it might be
because it you know the stuff that he
was shooting was his special he always
sounds nervous and uncomfortable on
stage my lovely genius farts we are here
to talk about purple my friends let's
keep my lights on so i'm not out in
these giving out hand jobs purple is a
lovely sponsor of this podcast because i
freaking love my purple mattress i don't
know how many times i can say it i love
my mattress i was just in south korea
and the biggest thing that i missed
about being back home was not my stupid
dog who loves me so much it's my purple
mattress that i didn't get to sleep in
for two weeks i dream of my mattress the
best sleep i've ever had in my life and
guess what my friends if you don't know
purple mattresses have this thing called
the gel flex grid it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy material that adapts and
flexes around pressure points and
doesn't retain heat if you're a hot
sleeper and you'd be sweating [ __ ] up
your nasty nasty boy or girl you need to
get yourself a purple mattress with that
gel flex grid i love my mattress listen
if you spend a [ __ ] ton of your life
sleeping you better make sure it counts
and let me tell you something if you get
yourself a purple mattress you will
never ever go back to another mattress
ever getting a great night's sleep
starts with having a great mattress get
a purple mattress go to purple.com
brain10 and use code brain10 for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
brain10 codebrain10 for 10 off any order
of 200 or more purple.com brain 10 promo
code brain 10 terms apply
a lot of [ __ ] fell short and super flat
i'm not this is not me as a comic per se
you know [ __ ] on him i'm just
talking about somebody who just wanted
to enjoy his special because there was
no way in my mind that his second
special was gonna be as bad as his first
one and it was true his second special
was way better but
it was not good though
the best part about his special was the
comment
section hilarious dude people roasting
them people were roasting and i
understand why he doesn't read comments
because i would kill myself yeah oh [ __ ]
what were they saying bro people are
like crazy
open up your phone
look look even if you do something
perfect say you made something perfect
the internet is still going to [ __ ] on
it so i was trying on youtube because i
was looking for this whole debacle [ __ ]
i typed in brendan schaub and it was
like terrible comedy not funny like
people have like people like dedicate
youtube channels of just like doing hit
jobs yeah that's that's so unnecessary
like that isn't this why are you trying
to attack him for being a bad comment
like take it easy first comment the
first comment is uh says this is brutal
from sad frog what do you some people
were saying yeah i think that side huge
huge improvement from his previous
special that's positive i like that
place
no no hold on a second literally three
days ago these comments were not this so
they've deleted a lot of comments maybe
they might have youtube might have gone
through there and like
they deleted every bad comment there's
no bad comment on you wow
there's not a single bad comment they
deleted all the bad comments some people
some said this isn't that bad write a
comment saying we're filming a podcast
right now i should have stuck i
literally was tackling my ass off
laughing at some of these comments oh so
some of them got deleted huh damn right
some of them a lot of them got deleted
all the negative comments got deleted
wow wow some of them were just like 5
000 comments on there it's all like
david's got emails it's like all your
[ __ ] comments have been deleted and
removed
he's like
a thousand notifications yeah they
deleted but what the [ __ ]
because the comments were hilarious
i'm so sad yeah they were it's not like
i said i'm not reveling in the fact that
he's getting roasted i'm saying that
some of these comic like these comments
are funny genius yeah so i'm saying like
that right joke look look if it i get it
it's mean but like if it's funny it has
value so let it let it live baby let it
go let it rock i'm gonna
come on guys like when on facebook like
we used to like one in middle school and
[ __ ] we'd leave our facebook open
your buddies would go to town and put
like a gay dude sucking you off or
something like that and like write this
whole caption about how you [ __ ] get
[ __ ] in the ass on the daily and you
love it and like at a middle school bro
that's like
but i would let it it was funny and i
would i wouldn't delete the i'd be like
yo i got caught slipping i left my
facebook open when i went to go take a
[ __ ] shouldn't have done that my buddy
got on there ruined my life
but it's funny i would leave it up there
so i think youtube's gotta abide by the
same honorable system and you were doing
that in middle school you're you're
you're
a mature man one guy got mad dude we
literally switched this [ __ ] to all this
like we photoshopped his face on some
guy like bdsm guy getting his ass banked
and like his family was super religious
and they he called us like who the [ __ ]
dude
he's like my mom won't even talk to me
anymore
and we're like damn that [ __ ] works so
good
yeah boys i said they deleted all the
best comments that is sad but let's just
say this right like i
like i said this is not a criticism of
him being a stand-up because i think
like people to go out of their way to
tell him how bad he is at stand up is
kind of uncalled for you know you don't
have to like his [ __ ] you don't have to
like a [ __ ] i can understand a comment
but you're making 30 minute videos
dissecting everything yeah yeah yeah
it's like that's like that's like a
little accessory
i get it you write a funny witty com
comment and it's funny that's cool but
damn dude 45 minutes on on premiere like
cutting [ __ ] together i think it takes a
lot of [ __ ] time editing is tedious
dog
i mean this whole thing started too also
because freddy shot said he was going to
sue tiger belly yeah and then he was
going to he was that makes no sense he
was also crazy filing a lawsuit against
um youtubers like that are defaming him
or you know or whatever what not so lame
you're never gonna win
the internet's gonna do what the
internet does yeah and they double down
it's also lame like it's just like
everyone is allowed to have an opinion
no one has to like you and people can
say what the [ __ ] they want to say and
it goes in all directions i i believe i
mean obviously there's there's
exceptions and there's [ __ ]
boundaries or whatnot but like you can't
start suing people because i don't watch
every video and i like every single
comment whether it's good or bad
right and it's not because i'm trying to
be next level [ __ ] it's just like some
of the comments too they don't like the
[ __ ] that i say but they kind of explain
it um i can see that and they give it a
little bit
algorithm yeah but if somebody comes up
and they're just like you're a [ __ ]
cum-guzzling [ __ ] you clap back real
quick i clap back and i like the [ __ ]
bang thank you like you are too right
cool like i i'll just like it it is what
it is and i understand he said that he
talked to his therapist and his
therapist suggested that he doesn't read
comments because it messes with him
mentally right yeah which i 100 agree
for sure probably a good idea but when
you go on a mission to go ahead and
start tearing people down and [ __ ] them
over doing people yeah over something
you heard from your team and nothing
and you didn't look into yourself
personally you have lost your [ __ ]
why would you not call the guy exactly
yeah just call him just call it
what's up i saw this thing is connected
to your email is this true and then hash
it out from there just call it don't
start with threats you know yeah that's
wild talk it out and he was saying that
oh when you start going after my family
and my money and my sponsors you
literally did that to ariel helwani
so you're kind of getting back what you
[ __ ] put out into the quote-unquote
universe so that's that just is what it
is but at the same time the people who
are going after you i still don't
believe the reddit thing and once again
he didn't show proof for it even though
he said he would so i'm trying to save
face i think he's trying to save face
because like i said he blew things out
of proportion he says he has 300 pages
which i think he just blurted that
number out
and it's probably like three or four
pages and he goes i have 300 pages of
evidence i have three million people joe
roman's gonna come after you he's going
to kill you and sidekick you into a room
into a room
just a big room i know george st pierre
he's going to beat you up in french yeah
you know he just starts saying these
things in his head he's like
i don't know man maybe i yeah i don't i
like i said i don't know him enough to
to like do a character analysis but from
the outside to a character analysis it
just seems like like off
the performance like especially like
with the stand up where like he's trying
really hard to perform
uh
almost as like a you know how like venom
the symbiote like takes over it's like
that it's like something like just he's
like because you said like off camera is
way chiller so it's like
i don't know i maybe he's trying too
hard and he like
it's like almost running downhill and
you can't stop yeah this is my theory
too because you know off camera two or
whatever you talk to him he's a super
cool dude right my problem with that is
that i think what happened to him and
once again this is all just theories and
me surmising just from the you know
whatever the hour interaction i have
with him the moment he tagged himself as
a comic he feels like he has to live up
to this expectation
so now when he started to try to be
funny is when he became less funny yeah
the moments that he had the best like
brendan shot funny moments were on joe
rogan's podcast when he wasn't labeling
himself a comic and he was saying these
off comment funny random bits and it was
good yeah but the moment he said i'm a
comic he keeps saying it too as a comic
me as being a comic you don't have to
keep who in the [ __ ] podcast space
who is a standard comic keeps calling
himself a comic he constantly does that
brendan you're in the comic i get it you
did two bad specials you're now a comic
you're there
we get it we [ __ ] get it dude you're
a comic i know you're a comic you go up
there you bomb every night
i'm kidding definitely a way better
comic than i am but at the end of the
day
where is it
i think for him
he just has to like stop taking yourself
so [ __ ] seriously what
i mean this happens a lot i think with
just like when you get into comedy
because you're right it's it's that
label kind of you're trying to figure
out your voice on stage and and really
what it is at least from what i've seen
the best guys that i've seen it's it's
it's almost like a circle like you start
comedy and you're like okay like how do
i tell a joke what do i do i'm scared of
[ __ ] on stage you got all these things
these skills you have to learn uh punch
lines setups suspense whatever however
you do it uh it but eventually you come
back to just being you on stage yeah and
that's those are the best guys the guys
that are like bill burr or louis or
chappelle like they they might
exaggerate certain things and they might
say things they don't not mean because
it's funny in the moment but essentially
they are being themselves so that's like
the final evolution when you get there
it's like that's when you get like a
killer headliner where you're like oh
this is and what i love about those
comics too when i hear their podcast
they always talk about oh last night do
i [ __ ] bond yeah like last time these
are legendary comments yeah and they
talk about how bad they did the night
before like i did two great sets the
other three sets i [ __ ] nobody
laughed yeah and these are amazing
comics i see they're refined special and
it makes i'm in tears laughing yeah but
they still have like the 50 moments
where their jokes just aren't hitting
yeah and the thing about that is too
like with brendan brennan's good about
making jokes about himself yeah and then
playing off of those jokes but when
somebody else makes fun of him he gets
he gets defensive he starts bringing out
facts or he starts stunning through and
he can't really joke along with it he
gets upset unless it's somebody like
theo vaughn who makes fun of him in a
ridiculous sense sure sure but when he
gets [ __ ] on he doesn't know how to roll
with these punches he thinks that he's
making fun of himself only when he makes
fun of himself yeah that's different
like when people are going at it and
you're bantering back and forth you
don't have to get hyper defensive about
everything like laughing
yeah like the cte joe so once you start
making fun of yourself about that and
you start rolling with these punches you
start making fun of like your your
inadequacies and it just becomes a joke
that everybody's laughing at he takes
himself way too [ __ ] seriously and i
think that's because also once again i'm
surmising he has a lot of pressure
because he was the golden boy child of
joe rogan so now he feels like he has to
live up to that expectation it's like
dude joe rogan and uh
tom's a girl whatever they wouldn't be
doing stand-up sets and shows with me if
i wasn't good yeah they would they 100
would he is a funny guy i have laughed
at some of his videos for sure it's it's
right there yeah but then just have to
figure it out he just needs to figure it
out and then
the people around him too like why
aren't you [ __ ] helping this dude man
i'm sure they are i think comedy is just
one of those things it's like a like i
don't know what some complicated baking
uh what's a [ __ ] like a thing that
takes forever to bake a cake a cake
a cake a cake it takes an hour to but on
minute 15 you're already like you'll be
a cake already it's like you can't it
just there's time is an element that
needs to you that's
that's also why comedy is so cool
because it's like i can tell somebody
that's never done comedy like these
things will make people laugh x y and z
follow these steps and they might get a
little chuckle here and there but you
have to [ __ ] do it and be in it and
just feel that fire that heat and then
you come out on the other side like okay
now i'm a comic you know what i mean but
there's a time element to it and
everyone's time is different eddie
murphy three years for some reason
michael jordan [ __ ] that happens other
guys 15 years other guys eight it just
that but that's what's so cool about it
it's so [ __ ] real and you have to go
through that furnace to figure it out on
your own
yeah and do it and also like to defend
like brendan too
you know for people to go in and just
start [ __ ] on him because he's
trying to be a comic and and i think
what happens is he's like god david
and that's all he says
and that's the end of the podcast guys
no no no
he's just cuts out he's going to defend
brandon cuts the shittiest comedy
special i've ever seen click
delete it again [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like
you know for people to go out of their
way to make a whole channel about how
much he sucks he's like listen we all
know this all right
like
you don't have to go out and [ __ ] on
this guy while he's down
like you know what i'm saying like go
down boy yeah the [ __ ] you know the
rotten tomato score says it all like
yeah you get it i'm just saying when you
open up adobe premiere to [ __ ] on
somebody that's like that's yeah that's
a big bro final cut i don't i don't
understand
damn dude like
that's just excuse me that's like like a
monthly investment
after effects
that's a lot of work
this is the thing get a job i understand
why you don't like his stand up but i
don't understand why you hate him for it
yeah i think why do you hate him for not
they can't respect
respect the attempt he's trying and i
was reading some of the comments
and people are saying that hey it's
because oh he doesn't deserve what he
has who the [ __ ] cares he has it now
what are you gonna do about it and yeah
still win it who are you to decide that
he doesn't deserve it yeah he's still
where the [ __ ] are you here are you [ __ ]
are you okay zeus unless you're out of
here
who are you
because clearly people do find him funny
because he has shows that are being sold
out so yeah somebody's finding him
entertaining
somebody why does this always sound bad
you say it like that bro somebody like
anything people there's a lot of people
that [ __ ] with brandon even even when
you're trying to say something nice
though i see this little glimmer in your
eyes the asian parent
that's the asian [ __ ]
it's like it's right there like it's
like i could take a turn here but
it's there though i see the thought
bubble i see that i see like you're
making it way worse than this he's gonna
beat me up now dude the iphone thought
bubblegum
and he goes
i'm just gonna say
all right
in order for this to truly be squashed
between like bobby and brendan i think
the only thing that brendan shot for the
whole stop oh let me do this yeah the
only thing
that bright shop can do is honestly he
has to go into room think about what he
did and then watch his special
that's punishment
which one though
which one back to back
oh [ __ ] they suck but listen
yeah
i knew it was there
i knew it was coming i knew i just want
to do it because it's so fun
and it's nice it's okay i gotta tell you
he's really cool to me he was super cool
to me and i'm really cool with him too
but i didn't like how he conducted
himself by the way i openly stated on
tiger belly that anybody [ __ ] with
bobby lee that i would [ __ ] them up but
it would just have to be brendan shaw
former ufc heavyweight fighter why out
of all the people that guy would kill me
yeah yeah he'd kill anybody in here dude
yeah he killed a big [ __ ] dude
i'll tell you i respect the guy though
man the guy has built a [ __ ] empire a
real also also respect for going on and
like trying like at least
that's a difficult conversation to have
because that [ __ ] was mad uncomfortable
that was uncommon like that was like he
didn't have to do that you know so he
went on there and at least i didn't see
the whole thing but from what i saw he
was pretty much willing to listen
and be like i [ __ ] up you know yeah i
don't i didn't hear the whole thing i
but
from the past i didn't watch any of it
yeah i saw the thumbnail i was like
really what it is i was trying to but
then i was like [ __ ] this is so awkward
and like it's just like i just want to
know yeah and it's high schooly and i
was like man what the [ __ ] and then
bobby lee i feel bad for bobby lee
because he just seemed sad yeah like he
literally had no like he was like just
chilling on monday
and it was tuesday and then there's all
this [ __ ] that cracked off like he's
just woke up like what the [ __ ] is going
on it sucks bobby lee is like the true
victim in this whole thing yeah and you
know bobby has his flaws too out in his
personal life but we can't bring up his
passion for this specifics
no one's perfect yeah no one's perfect
every bobby lee is definitely not
perfect but in this case like you said
this case
like
he actually he's just blind
was involved [ __ ] on him everybody was
just like
trying to cancel this shots
well you know the whole thing about
brian callan you know like his or them
yeah yeah yeah the funniest part about
that podcast is literally him explaining
to brennan how technologically inept he
is
and then later on in the podcast he
confirms it he goes dude we could go
ahead and just let's go find the email
and let's compare emails to email and he
goes what's our email
[Laughter]
literally doesn't know anything
oh my god damn that's her email yeah
that's the whole podcast is two guys who
don't know how the internet works yeah
that's what it is that's why i'm like
this is so stupid it really is it really
is it blew up out of [ __ ] nothing
seems like yeah like whoa
it just doesn't make any sense what's
your final piece of advice to squash all
this for real i think brendan shop just
needs to just [ __ ] stay in your lane
bro just
just do you you're doing perfectly fine
like if you truly don't give a [ __ ]
about the comments or whatever even if
it was some comic that you knew that was
talking [ __ ] behind your back who the
[ __ ] cares they're not your friends
they're not in your circle let them talk
[ __ ] yeah let them you have no idea how
much people talk [ __ ] about me it always
comes to me all the time what do people
say about you davidson oh my god that
i'm loud i'm rude that i always have
opinions about their work which is a
hundred percent true yeah
it's uh that's why i'm not mad at that
it's like yeah dude there was somebody
that i won't say their name i did a
podcast about how much i hated the movie
that he was in all right his name rhymes
with bang b bang me it was a movie named
baby boom boom and i heard through the
grapevine that this fool was mad at me
yeah because i didn't like his the movie
that he was in it's like dude
movie was kind of whack yeah
and also
also did you
make this movie
yeah hey i'm happy for you you made
money i do movie reviews
movies i'm not supposed to review it
hey let's be honest though
it was kind of whack oh yeah dude but i
loved it so much
i need a camera for just that sign i
when i saw that in theaters i was like
yo it was pretty good and then you know
caught up in the hype
hold up bro
let me explain myself talking to hype i
can't like a movie the first time i
watched you get excited i can't have i
can't have different opinions after
watching it at home go ahead any
supremacists go ahead go go go so
taiwan's not a country um no but
wow whoa dude no so i watched it a
second time whoa and and it was to me
it yeah it wasn't as good the second
time listen all i needed was one time
the movie wasn't like a one i'm just
saying it wasn't good it wasn't a one
yeah there was just a lot of things that
were just [ __ ] what was better
brightness special or
bang b oh let me tell you something yes
that's a tough one
i will say this shanxi was ten times
better than special and at least i got
something out of it and what did you get
out of it huh we had the uplifting of
our culture true right michelle yo
michelle yo
[ __ ] love yeah uh nora who i [ __ ]
love yeah aquafina dope [ __ ] also two
dope ass fight scenes the fourth the
fight fights were [ __ ] scenes were
sick fire and also he looked good doing
those fight scenes fine scenes were cool
and tony liu
tony liu hey sai mulu that guy did his
own stunts yeah really yeah he did his
own stunts letterman jacket i heard too
there it is [ __ ] that's pretty good if
you guys ever go to disneyland right and
you get to go to the avengers area
you'll see the guy who plays uh shang
chi and it's just a guy from like uc
irvine wearing a letterman jacket
i'm like bro that's so [ __ ] up
how come everybody gets a suit but shake
cheeks yeah bro bro but disrespectful
give me a jacket they couldn't give a
bro and he was wearing vans i was like
yo you guys can give him a costume he
was just a guy like you gonna give him a
suit of armor or something like in the
movie like he's wearing jeans and then
like they gave him that [ __ ] the best
the letterman's jacket the dragon skin
vest and i was like what the [ __ ] is he
had fans on in the final scene i was
like this is what he's gonna fight his
dad with with the ten rings that's the
thing i was upset i'm like why did they
[ __ ] screw over this guy and give him
just skinny jeans and vans and then a
scaly vest you guys are such [ __ ]
make him take his shirt off the dude's
jacked you know all the time in the
comic book this [ __ ] is wearing
just like the bruce lee pants and he's
and he's jacked right that's that's his
outfit
you guys can do that yeah they could
even make him look [ __ ] dope as [ __ ]
yeah some superhero [ __ ] well see like
well that's all i said about that's so
funny dude but for some reason the guy
thought i'm taking a shot at him it's
like
you you're not you know you're not shang
chi right like you're a person you're
like you're a human being you're not
shang chi you're not this person in this
movie yeah i do movie reviews
i'm going to review this movie that
people ask yeah that sucked
if it's so style you know i mean
there are some positives like you said
there were some possible and i said the
positives
which is great too by the way and listen
i don't dislike that guy at all i just
did a movie review and that's all that
it is same thing with brenda's shop i
don't know him personally i'm only
talking about the stuff that i saw on
the on the podcast yeah like i said have
i given some advice is maybe cool your
[ __ ] jets before you go on this full
whole sue happy thing you hear that
because pull your jets guys for five i
understand he goes five years i've been
taking this this verbal abuse brendan so
has everybody else yeah have you seen
the reddit thread on me dude there was
this funny ass reddit thread it's not
funny but it's funny but it's funny
because they said that i was i was i
entrapped
mariel that she was in an abusive
relationship because on the podcast i
said i was gonna punch her in the [ __ ]
which is clearly a joke yeah obviously
but they did a whole tick tock and they
put it on reddit oh my god
look at her eyes she looks like she's
trapped people are crazy speculations i
showed it to ariel and she was cracking
up she's like what the [ __ ] what is this
like i don't know i feel like brendan
like the will smith thing is like like
you know how will smith like just
snapped and finally just slapped a
[ __ ] because he's been dealing
with all this [ __ ] it's like brendan
chob's version of that you know what i
mean where he didn't slap anybody but
he's like went because it makes no sense
to pop off that much yeah
over celebrating all you could have done
was just
hey bobby so i heard about this stuff is
this true
and even then i wouldn't even gone that
far i would have just been like whatever
i wanna just yeah just yeah like what's
going on
because i really don't believe that
investigation thing is true but i also i
just don't believe it it sounds like
they just don't understand how reddit
works either yeah i don't know
there's no [ __ ] way on a reddit
thread where there's a bunch of people
who are clearly saying in fact like
inflammatory things like
throughout the whole space which none of
it is actual clear evidence that they're
using that as a foundation to go after
it why would bobby lee do that
what is the most the guy doesn't even
brush his teeth why why what what what
he has seven teeth left in his mouth how
what the [ __ ] do you think he's gonna do
on there to go and take you down he
wakes up at 6 00 p.m what reason
i don't know there's no reason there's
no it just that's what i'm saying it
makes zero sense
if anything he should have given him the
benefit doubt because he calls him his
brother
he says he loves him
that's his boy should talk to him
exactly and all brian cowan's the worst
of all he's the one that i'm so sad
about yeah
that makes no sense to me either
brendan i get it he's a little
hot-headed maybe a little cte doesn't
really know bobby like that but brian
keller knows i feel wild bro yeah brian
callan he knows him like that and you
know i i thought for the longest time
with brian callan that his tough guy
[ __ ] was a bit yeah me too uh he's not a
bit it's real he's actually a genius
he thinks he's mr tough guy
yeah what is this i thought it was a
joke too
it was a good bit too
like there was this clip of of
joe rogan and brendan [ __ ] on brian
callan because brian campbell was like
dude if somebody ever bullies me i'll go
to their house and i'll [ __ ] them up and
then joe's just like dude cut this [ __ ]
out nobody that actually would do that
would talk about it yeah and joe rogan
was like your problem is is that you
hang around with a bunch of dudes that
talk just like you and all you guys
wouldn't do [ __ ]
and joe rogan is calling him out yeah he
goes all of you guys just just feed into
this [ __ ] none of you would do any
of that type of stuff yeah and then
brendan's like oh you don't think i
would like i would [ __ ] do that but i
thought he was doing a bit like a joke
yeah but it wasn't that that's him
that's pretty wild and now i'm sad i'm
sad as [ __ ] because i think he's so
[ __ ] funny he is funny it's hard to
like watch him now because now i know
that's not a bit it's just it's him
that shit's wild what do you do here
what do you do i don't know man i think
i think it's just
i mean yeah
if you're bobby lee and you just keep on
keeping on to keep doing what you're
doing i mean i just like i said i just
feel bad for him and it's just gonna
take time but uh brendan's shop yeah i
don't know it seems like he's
burning a lot of bridges you know mm-hmm
and it's just like what the what would i
be this shit's dumb as [ __ ] we've all
had and look i'm not saying i'm above
anything because we've all had our our
personal dramas too of course we had it
on this podcast on this podcast with
like jk film drama stuff that we all had
to figure out in squash but
i
it would it never went to the point like
this like this is crazy [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean yeah this is weird
crazy [ __ ] it is so i i don't know man
bread and shop dude listen man if you
wanna come on this podcast and give me
some views
you wanna bless this podcast
by the way i am gonna have seven
bodyguards here yeah all fully armed
with guns yeah and nick and machetes
yeah and just in case you go zero to a
hundred on my ass for a [ __ ] reason
yeah yeah you know damn dude hey what
happened with the amber heard oh you
told me this what's going on because you
told me something okay what are the
updates well she's been on the witness
stand so they're they're act they're
cross-examining her and then her
explanations of most things are just
very sus like she just she's super sexy
she just sounds like she's just lying
about everything and she's like she's
constantly contradicting herself like
she's literally
making stuff up on the spot and it's so
bad it it hurts me to watch oh my god
much like
yeah
much like what much
yeah is there anything that you could
like compare it to that you've seen
recently that you're like not really
happy just hurts your soul a little bit
yeah something that's like
so bad you guys continually try to make
me look bad
like is there anything that you can
compare her acting performance to that
you just like don't really like in terms
of entertainment like equality and just
quality yeah yeah wow amber hurt
the funniest thing this is one clip that
everybody saw that had me dying laughing
that i don't think people realized how
funny it is it's her just on the spot
trying to put evidence against uh johnny
depp which she clearly didn't speak with
her lawyer about yeah about him having a
jar of cocaine her poor lawyers yeah she
just goes like oh yeah and then i saw
him he had this jar which you know when
i think about it now it was clearly
cocaine a jar of cocaine and like she
just thought about it on the spot yeah
i'm like did you literally just say on
stand
that you just when i think about it now
it was clearly a jar of cocaine i could
just picture her lawyer going what
the
[ __ ] i feel like that's constant too i
feel her lawyers are so dumb that they
probably were like yeah that's dope got
him guys do her lawyers chase close
actively like trying to
question her while she's on the stand
like kind of like feeding her like hey
these are the things that are wrapping
the ball yeah these are the things that
we talked about
the johnny depp's lawyers are like
hearsay leading the witness blah blah
blah saying all this stuff and the
lawyer just like [ __ ] we got nothing we
can't we can't get this chick to
remember her lines right her fake crying
[ __ ] is the funniest part so people have
recorded
specific parts of her forgetting that
she has to still act
so she'll be super smart where she goes
and then my dog
steps on a bee
and she starts crying and she goes it's
like hold on and her face was like
and it's like i don't even know what she
was trying to talk about but the funny
part about that is like that's not the
part where you cry amber
yeah you're supposed to cry later yeah
not at this part of the story i think
she forgot you missed your cue yeah she
missed her cue she was my dog stepped on
a beat
it's like yo hold on a second what are
you doing and so throughout the court
case you'll see these clips
and i and i i watched like a ten minute
it wasn't a clip it was just the whole
thing and it was her crying and then
when they give her another question in
between they're deliberating and she
forgets that she still has to continue
to cry oh so she just goes
whoa
psycho straight face and i think at that
moment she starts to realize that she's
not crying anymore and then she starts
getting all sad again so there's these
moments where she's forgetting to
continue to
act which is so insane that is insane
yeah and so you'll see a compilation of
her crying and then stop crying and just
kind of staring off whoa because she
forgot
what a [ __ ] lunatic dude how long is
this [ __ ] trial huh yeah it's pretty
obvious that she's full of [ __ ] but i
told you like ukraine war is over yeah
and nobody cares
nobody cares yeah what's good is
stopping the war right yeah 100 nobody's
fighting in russia right now
we must watch these go down please
please don't
don't step on the beat
what happened
you'd step on me you cry please
don't care please i saw i saw a clip of
um she was getting off the stand and
like kind of jury the court was like
kind of like
everyone was like getting up to go out
or something and johnny depp kind of
like says something i think a juror i
don't know who he was talking to but he
shakes hands with somebody and she sees
them and they're like kind of close and
she like
the worst acting ever and the security
guards had to come in like
like something was going to happen like
he was going to like stab her in the
neck or something yeah in court who
knows
damn bro and so johnny depp 2 in court
he's always wearing sunglasses and he's
never making eye contact with her
because he literally said you will never
ever meet my eyes ever again you will
never look because there's nothing
behind her that's like a vampire curse
or something
you'll never beat my eyes you will never
lock eyes on me
curse it's an ancient medieval [ __ ]
that's some medieval [ __ ] dude yeah and
so he's in the courtroom and he's not
looking at her ever he always has
sunglasses on that dude's charismatic as
[ __ ] dude dude he's helped me wins dude
you talk about somebody should do a
special for the first time yeah johnny
depp i just went that boy got some jokes
dude yeah i dropped a grumpy you know
when you guys watch the trout do you
guys ever think like all those people
sitting in the back
they're just they're just probably just
bystanders right they're just random
people that just walk in legally you can
walk in you can go to a court like if
you wanted to and just walk in and sit
down and watch a case like that that's
your real that's your right as a citizen
yeah can we do that i'm pretty sure i
mean i might have just i might have just
made that up let's look that up
i'm pretty sure look okay this is
something this is your american right
this is this is the fighter and the kid
we just do things off here say okay
i've definitely been in court [ __ ] and
look i've been in court for like my
personality
well i walked in and no one checked me
in or anything i could i could have just
been a guy homie in the step hey what's
up
there's no there's no like guard at the
front door that's like hey why are you
here you walk in you go through a
security [ __ ] thing and then you
could just walk into any court like you
can pop your head really i i mean i
could have walked in i could have walked
into another courtroom and probably sat
there and no one was like hey why are
you here like it's just like
you're just a guy in the room i didn't
know that i'm pretty sure you can i
think it's your i think
is that like civil court though
i there might be certain cases where
that's not allowed because i know like
remember just lane delay just lane they
didn't let cameras in her thing because
it's like i guess federal cases are
different and so they have a [ __ ]
artist instead of someone just taking
pictures yeah some dude they should
still film it why are you still that's
the outdated as [ __ ] you got some dudes
with color pencils in the corner like
just take a [ __ ] picture with your
eyeballs
um
it's being recorded
there's a video camera in there where
would you like in the courtroom oh yeah
what's the point of drawing the whole
thing out
do you want to show talent somebody
right now is pissed at us because like
that's my job what is that wait what is
that where do you go on indeed and go i
want to be the colored pencil guy in
courtrooms like who's i think it's just
one of those old things that they just
want to keep around [ __ ] they should
bring back the people you know it's
weird too is the cloaks the judges wear
these [ __ ] weird wizard robes kind of
weird that either you get the only
places that wear them is the judge and
when you get your hair cut at a barber
shop
like that's the only people buying
these wizard cloaks are those you ever
been uh called in for a jury duty
yeah
no i have oh you're lucky well i got
called in a few times but you know i
can't go because i'm the only source of
income for myself so you call me and i'm
[ __ ] yeah like i can't leave because
if it gets called in i'm gone for a week
you can't pay me for a whole week yeah
like i literally cannot do this i don't
think they pay you [ __ ] nothing
anyway like 20 bucks a day yeah bro
that's for parking anyway you just got
to be crazy in the jury selection did
you get that shouldn't even work what do
you mean i heard if you walk in and
you're like i'm a white supremacist
they're probably not going to pick
they'll be like yeah nice try come on
yeah go let's have a very specific bias
so it's like
it's got to be subtle enough yeah so my
friend that got called in it was like
this thing for like uh
uh someone's like bank robbery or type
of [ __ ] right but then he said like
listen like my family has a bunch of
felonies my brother just is in prison
for for jacking cars like i don't feel
comfortable with this [ __ ]
but that's a bias
yeah
so you just gotta it's gotta be subtle
enough yeah but he's gonna be this way
truthful it was honest but that's the
reason why because he had a bias in the
court case and they they wouldn't allow
them to be on yeah but uh i haven't been
called because well i i got called like
two or three times but i can't do it
because it's a waste of time dude yeah
it's like you can't there's no way that
if i'm the sole person in my business
you can't take me away for two weeks i'm
[ __ ] like it's not going to work out
dude [ __ ] all that you get like you you
sit there and watch this [ __ ] yeah
dude i'm pretty sure there's a lot of
old people that want to do it for free
there's some i've met people that are
like i want to be called and i'm like
well you're [ __ ] nuts dude you know i
mean
[ __ ] weirdo huh what the [ __ ] would
you want to be called that [ __ ] boring
as [ __ ] it wastes your whole [ __ ]
even just like getting almost getting
selected it just wastes like three days
at your [ __ ] life and you have to be
at the courtroom the courthouse all
[ __ ] day for three days it's it's
annoying court sucks dude the only
reason why you get
called to court after you register to
vote or yeah that's why i don't register
to vote right no because i wasn't i
wasn't no honestly you're not trying to
get jury duty okay i think you could
still get called without without being
registered at least if you're a citizen
right you have to get called they'll
find you i should have kept my green
card bro they'll find you
they'll find you
there's a little guy walks up to you and
he's like hey i'm like oh what is this
and i'm like [ __ ]
this picture
picture of his dick
oh my god this is where we're gonna end
the podcast
well let me end the podcast on this oh
[ __ ] let's go
my god amen it's just expensive as [ __ ]
damn you gotta drink it up listen
final words i love brendan shaw yeah all
right yeah yeah all these jokes oh look
at me bro look at the camera yeah
is simply because i like making jokes
yeah i don't have a personal vendetta
against you she already talks to us yeah
the way that we talk about this guy
right here you want to talk about some
[ __ ] suing you shoot the [ __ ] out of
me
[Laughter]
whole podcast about [ __ ] defamatory
language just evidence i literally said
his skin looks like a band-aid yeah yeah
it's just hours of everything that bad
though like let's be real listen i look
like a band-aid don't don't don't chop
up this whole thing and then it's gonna
get you i just feel like one of the
channels that make you know brenda's
shop [ __ ] stuff they're gonna chop up my
thing oh dude and brendan when your team
gets a hold of this i want you to call
me directly and then we'll talk about it
this is not going to make it in the
final cut listen i need
views so
i want you to come on this podcast yeah
and then defend yourself
at all costs because i i will back you
up verbally don't you you assault me
i'll tell you this i will scream so
[ __ ] loud they will my relatives in
korea are gonna hear you
i [ __ ] dare you to touch me dude you
wanna talk about a [ __ ] lawsuit
coming oh oh white people sue the [ __ ]
out of you dude why people stop
especially because i lost all my money
in crypto
all right so let me go
i'm about to suck some dick out in these
streets
you can find patrick at patrick.t.reilly
on instagram doing a stand-up thang
check him out on his show
boo him for me
we got nick the ear you could catch him
at lion heart
uh jiu jitsu academy
i'm in pasadena shout out to our boy uh
origami i know he didn't ask me to plug
his thing but i'm doing it anyways
because i like you because you're sweet
he's a gem yeah check out lionheart jiu
jitsu uh
uh nick is gonna be teaching classes you
can check out nte strong for that
physical education type of needs bang
bang and programs coming soon on
instagram geniusbrain every sunday's at
12pm we'll see you all next time [ __ ]